communist china reportedly getting ready
to bail out vladimir putin the u.s and
nato allies hitting russia right where
it hurts as you know with these harsh
sanctions and the banning of russian
blood oil the kremlin vowing to fight
back saying america has declared an
all-out economic war but then russia
turns to china and china could be
tossing putin a financial life preserver
considering they are we are told uh
buying stakes in russia's energy sector
so but china will just uh you know take
up the slack for russia absolutely i
mean these two guys think alike of
course they're going to take care of
each other and you know what are you
surprised that they're friends i'm not
surprised at all and when when he says
it's an all-out economic war putin it
goes right back to what i was saying and
i think it was in the a-block when i was
talking about the fact that who knows
what what new hurdle or what new
standard he's going to use for you know
triggering him it's an economic war so
therefore i'm going to be at war with
all of you but no i think that i think
they should be very happy together but
the problem is that if we go to electric
vehicles and all that that we're going
to have some trouble with with lithium
and and some of the other uh materials
that we need see i go back to the money
thing
uh jesse
i i think china wants to make money
china's in exists to make money and to
get more and more powerful this is very
bad for business
it is no europe turmoil everybody
suspicious of the other it is bad for
business but they're going to go in and
raid all the commodities out of russia
they're going to go after their timber
and their coal and their oil and their
gas but after commodities they don't
have anything in russia and then they're
you look at china you look at china and
you look at russia and you think that's
disgusting you don't want to have any
association with russia and then you're
going to have some guy come in the
chinese and and act like they're sugar
daddy no so they're going to face
boycotts they're going to face sanctions
if you're going to come in and deal with
the russians then you're going to have
western banking institutions say no you
stay over there so they're going to have
to decide
you know are they going to de-link
themselves from the global economy and
deal deals with a pariah state that's
going bankrupt or do they want to you
know keep propping up their economy with
western cash and at least try to be seen
as a normal stakeholder and not some
disgusting you know communist regime
that's bailing out
a war criminal
what about taiwan
what about here you have this island
china threatening to take it over the
way they took over hong kong but
militarily they want to take over taiwan
uh will this give china the feeling that
america is a toothless tiger anyway that
now is the time to take time
it is interesting that
president xi has this opportunity to see
how it would go so he told putin that to
wait until after the olympics and which
tells me also
xi doesn't think of putin as an equal
at all he thinks of putin as subpar
and i think he also thinks that this was
pitiful the way that this has gone down
and that it looks awful and we even
heard yesterday that the germans and the
french were talking to the chinese about
figuring out a way to try to find peace
talks i think that i think that the
chinese look at putin and think like if
it had gone perfectly according to all
the things that greg mentioned that all
the assumptions the four assumptions
that putin had that all of that had
worked out perfectly i think beijing
would have said well then next fall
after our big communist meeting maybe we
just go ahead and figure out a way to
take taiwan that might have gotten
harder now but one of the things that
china will figure out in addition to the
economic things that you've uh mentioned
is that the oil will be available to
them to buy they have a voracious
appetite and they've been helping iran
for many years get out of the situation
with the sanctions of the rest of the
world china doesn't care they'll buy
their oil so there might be a way for
putin to at least
keep afloat in some way but i agree it's
not a very attractive dance partner that
china is looking at here and yet greg
when you look at a map if you have a map
at home folks take a look at
china and russia together they tell they
take up an awful lot big hunk of the
world well you know what this is what i
hope i hope dana's right but it's not
just the world it's the final frontier
i don't want a partnership between china
and russia because they're going to need
to be partners
if we're talking about space and or
owning that space because basically that
should be ours but if those two guys get
get together we're screwed but you're
right you know if if russia does does
end up hooking up with china
they have to be china's puppet yep how
can it be anything else because you if
they have all your bank they have all
your bank stuff right because they're
going to do the bank stuff they're going
to buy your oil like what can putin do
that's putin is